qu'est ce que nous aimons chez les
machines nous sommes entourés en
permanence par tout un tas de machines
je vous aurais mis quelques unes ici
mais même si j'avais voulu je n'aurais
pas pu mettre toutes les machines d'un
seul d'entre vous a utilisé depuis ce
matin alors si nous sommes à ce poids
entouré une machine c'est qu'on doit
bien leur trouver quelque chose
qu'est ce donc qu en commun et qu'on
aime bien visiblement un lave linge et
un smartphone à bien j'ai posé la
question à mon entourage je leur ai
demandé ce qu'ils aiment chez les
machines et voilà ce que j'ai obtenu est
bien d'abord on demande aux machines
d'être utile de faire quelque chose
d'utile pour nous mais on leur demande
aussi tout un tas d'autres qualités
qu'on ne trouve pas forcément en tout
cas pas forcément tous les jours chez
nous chez les humains comme être
efficace être précis être rapide ou
encore être prédictible on aime savoir à
l'avancé ce que va faire une machine
c'est moins facile et chez les humains
alors à quoi ressemblerait un monde avec
des machines encore plus performante
leur demande d'être performante qui se
passa si elle était encore plus
performante et bien j'ai fait une thèse
en robotique durant laquelle j'ai
travaillé sur les véhicules du futur
les véhicules autonomes c'est à dire que
j'ai poussé le vice franchement loin
jusqu'à donner le contrôle d'une machine
une voiture à une autre machine un
ordinateur qui conduit la voiture à la
place du conducteur
et voilà à quoi ressemblerait un monde
avec des véhicules autonomes un monde où
personne n'attend viol
un monde où les véhicules consomment
moins d'énergie
un monde où même si on a du mal à le
croire en voyant la vidéo il y aurait
moins l'accident un monde plus
performant alors aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de machines fantastiques
c'est le titre en tout cas vous devez
vous dire que je vais vous parler de ce
genre de machine là les machines du
futur les véhicules autonomes
et robots humanoïdes les machines super
performante et bien non pas du tout
c'est tout le contraire dont je vais
vous parler ce que je vous propose
aujourd'hui c'est de nous libérer des
contraintes de performance peut-on
fabriquer une machine nouvelle originale
mais qui n'aille pas vers plus de
rapidité plus de précisions une machine
qui ne rend pas notre monde plus
performants voire peut-être qui le rend
un peu moins performant et bien je vais
vous raconter une expérience que j'ai
réalisés ces derniers mois
l'imagination et la fabrication d'une
machine sans contraintes de performance
et sans plus attendre je vais vous
montrer un produit de cette expérience
qui va arriver sur scène là de façon un
peu grandiloquente voilà
attention aux têtes
bon alors je vous avais prévenu ça va
peut être tomber d'ailleurs on n'est pas
du tout dans les critères de performance
voilà je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
pour dire que tout au moins au premier
abord mais peut-être même au deuxième
cette machine n'a pas franchement le
look d'une machine fantastique
alors qu'est ce que c'est que cet objet
et surtout qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
fabriquer les recettes d'objets c'est
une imprimante
ça a été mon point de départ
fabriquèrent une imprimante mais comme
vous pouvez le voir depuis mon point de
départ jusqu'à ici je me suis légèrement
éloignée
alors quels sont les deux grandes
caractéristiques d'une imprimante
première grande caractéristique une
imprimante imprime sur du papier c'est
bien pratique quand les feuilles peuvent
s'empiler s'est facilement manipulables
par la machine
on peut facilement le stocker et le
transporter première caractéristique
deuxième grande caractéristique une
imprimante une imprimante un flim avec
de l'encré
à nouveau c'est bien pratique parce que
bien langue permet de fixer de façon
durable le message sur le papier et en
plus de ça vu que ces liquides on peut
faire des toutes petites gouttes qu'on
va pouvoir les jeter sur le papier pour
imprimer de façon extrêmement précise
alors comment je suis passé de mon point
de départ à ça et bien en questionnant
ses certitudes et si une imprimante
l'imprimé pas sur du papier et si une
imprimante n'imprimez pas avec de
l'encré et si une imprimante son
résultat le résultat de la pression
n'était pas quelque chose de durable
mais au contraire quelque chose
d'éphémère quelque chose d'évolutif
elias et en pesant ses caissons que je
suis passé de la à cette machine une
imprimante à g de lentilles c'est à dire
que au lieu d'imprimer en déposant de
langue sur du papier
ld l'imprimante à g de lentilles dépose
des graines de lentilles sur un plateau
de terre alors comment cela fonctionne
et bien en fait de façon assez
classique pour une imprimante on a un
premier degré liberté là c'est le tapis
roulant sur lequel on dépose le plateau
de terre il ya ensuite comme dans
n'importe quelle imprimante une buse
mais au lieu alors elle se déplace sur
un axe perpendiculaire et au lieu de
dépose de contenir de lancre et bien le
contient des graines de lentilles à
partir de là vous avez un petit moteur
qui va générer des vibrations qui vont
faire tomber les lentilles aux endroits
souhaité pour former l'image ce joli
coeur la voilà alors eh bien ligne par
ligne
l'image est formé et il ne reste plus
qu'à recouvrir de terre à arroser à être
patients et à laisser faire la nature
pour obtenir une impression végétales
alors ce que je vous montre ici c'est
une photo un instantané trois jours
après avoir déposé les graines
mais ce qui est intéressant est un peu
original dans l'impression à lentille
c'est sans caractère évolutif son
caractère éphémère
alors en fait ce qui est agréable c'est
de se lever chaque matin et de voir
quelque chose de différent
alors pour essayer de vous donner un peu
ce sentiment là je vais vous montrer
l'évolution d'une impression c'est un
mot en anglais
je ne vous dis pas encore lequel et
voilà ce que cela donne un prix mais le
premier jour après un jour alors je
pense que pas grand monde ici arrive
déjà deviner le mot qui est écrit
peut-être on sait jamais ça marche pas
vous me cassez tout mon effet bon now
mais effectivement en tout cas ce qu'on
voit déjà c'est sûr c'est que la terre
commença à se soulever
sous la pression des germes un peu comme
si le mot poussé pour essayer
d'apparaître mais il n'apparaît pas
encore le deuxième jour cette fois-ci
vous tout le monde doit arriver à
deviner le mot est bien les tiges des
petits bouts de tiji versant sortie et
est bien le mot commence à apparaître
mais un peu un peu timidement finalement
et ce n'est que le troisième jour que
les tiges vont être assez verte est
assez garni pour que tout le monde
puisse lire distinctement le message
le mot dhuime alors il a fallu trois
jours pour qu'apparaisse le mot et on y
peut absolument rien c'est la nature qui
a décidé ça en plus de ça on est obligé
d'imprimer sa en très grand parce que
bien en termes de précision on est
limité par la taille d'une lentille
c'est pas nous qui avons décidé on n'y
peut rien nouveau cd nature et enfin si
vous imprimez plusieurs fois ce mode
dream
vous n'obtiendrez jamais la même chose
pourquoi parce que au moment où les
graines germent elle se déplace très
légèrement sur la terre et même elles
font déplacer la paire elle même si bien
que chaque impression est unique
à nouveau on n'y peut rien c'est la
nature
alors ce que je vous propose maintenant
de faire dream
enfin je vais vous dire une chose
d'abord c'est que cette machine comme on
le voit je pense pour conclure ne
propose pas d'imprimer de façon plus
performantes
peut-être même qu'elle propose de
supprimer deux raisons moins performante
mais surtout elle propose d'imprimer
différemment en collaborant laborieuse
normes avec la nature alors dhuime je
disais j'ai pas choisi ce mot
complètement au hasard
ce que je vous propose de faire
maintenant justement c'est de laisser
cet objet un peu insolite nous faire
rêver d'essayer d'imaginer un monde où
cette machine ne serait justement pas un
objet insolite où ce serait un objet de
la vie de tous les jours comme votre
lave-linge
j'essaie d'imaginer un monde comme celui
là un peu je me suis mis en fait dans la
peau d'un archéologue qui auront fait
des fouilles des centaines d'années plus
tard corée pour retrouver ces machines
et qui seraient demandés comment on
vivait à l'époque
alors pour vous retranscrire cette
histoire ce monde imaginaire
je vais justement vous raconter une
histoire une histoire qui se passe a
beau matin dans le monde fantastique des
lentilles
c'est l'histoire d'une petite fille et
de son papa qui sont dans le jardin ils
sont en train de disposer minutieusement
des graines de lentilles sur des
plateaux de terre pour écrire la carte
des prix du pain et oui le papa est
boulanger et sa fille adore écrire
chaque semaine le prix des pins avec son
papa d'ailleurs tous les soirs avant de
se coucher elle prépare les graines
qu'elle va utiliser le lendemain matin
parfois même elle se met à parler avec
les graines alors qu'est ce que vous
préférez être utilisée plus tôt pourrir
le prix n'est pas pour faire des dessins
pour écrire des lettres à mes amis etc
et ce n'est qu'après ces longues
négociations que la petite fille mais à
tremper les graines toute la nuit dans
des bacs d'eau distincts avant d'aller
se coucher
et ce matin comme tous les premiers
matins à la semaine la petite fille
écrit le prix des pins avec son papa
mais ça matin et bien une question dit
papa pourquoi aurait écrit chaque
semaine le prix dépeint comme ça avec
les lentilles c'est toujours le même on
pourrait pas trouver une solution pour
l'écrire une fois pour toutes je n'y
réponds sans papa il ya très longtemps
un jeune homme a écrit sur une pancarte
en grand avec de l'encré indélébile
qu'il avait la plus belle chevelure
blonde et bouclée que le monde ait
jamais connu il a collé ça c'est la
façade de chez lui pour que tout le
monde le sache
le temps est passé et quelques années
plus tard il n'avait plus un feu il a
bien essayé de coller de décoller la fij
d'effacer mais rien n'y faisait et tout
le village se moquer de 8,6 nous
écrivons aux lentilles ma fille c'est
pour réfléchir encore et toujours à ce
que nous écrivons bon mais aller au
travail soit parce que je parle qui vont
arrêter d'écrire un et la petite fille
reprend son travail
de toute façon elle sait bien que son
papa raconte des bêtises que cet homme
n'a jamais existé et que si on écrit en
lentilles dans son monde
c'est tout simplement pour faire plaisir
aux lentilles
voilà donc le monde fantastique des
lentilles que nous amène à imaginer
cette machine alors ce que nous montrent
cette expérience c'est qu'en imaginant
et en fabriquant un objet différent en
est amenée à imaginer un monde un
univers différents et fabriqué c'est
quelque chose qui nous est tout à fait
inédit tout à fait naturel on le voit
bien chez les à main les gamins ils
passent leur temps à fabriquer fabriquer
des bonhommes en lego en pâte à modeler
fabriquer des châteaux de sable ou
encore fabriquer des fusées faut le plus
ambitieux et s'il est si agréable de
faire de riz qui sait que lorsque nous
fabriquons les objets qui nous entourent
en fait nous fabriquons nous
construisons nous nous façonnons le
monde qui nous entoure lui-même à
nouveau les archéologues ont bien
compris puisque ils reconstruisent le
monde ancien et ils essayent de
comprendre comment on vivait à l'époque
à partir des objets qui l'on retrouve
alors aujourd'hui il ya tout un
mouvement est une communauté les maker
qui est bien essayé de fabriquer le plus
possible des objets qui les entourent
alors est ce que vous voulez construire
votre monde notre monde en contribuant à
l'imagination et la fabrication d'objets
différents grâce à sept comités de mike
heures vous avez aujourd'hui des lieux
ça s'appelle les fab lab dans lesquels
vous pouvez trouver à la fois cette
communauté et des machines pour vous
aider à fabriquer à fabriquer des objets
différents
voilà je vous invite tout simplement a
retrouvé le plaisir de ce talent inné
fabriquer fabriquer des objets
différents pour proposer un monde
différent
merci